le réseau de mesure intégration soleil e
imagination
[des rires]
iCloud
entre les bières et bien jouer on a fini
faire une chanson
le lendemain jour deux de
confinement on s'est dit ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui non
nous n'avons rien à faire
nous avons plus de bières nous avons plus d'olives
et les pommes de terre bien c'est reparti et
nous étions encore ici et nous allons
faire une autre chanson
de cette façon le club muet qui est
univers le sujet de l'étirement
le voisin vous êtes ceux du
ces chansons qui défilent
Internet que nous aimons
fou fou
[Musique]
Mons
ils utilisent
[Musique]
pour la perception musicale et soudain
nous obtenons cela vous connaissez la terrasse et ils sont al
vent et un de safina parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
aussi d'ici là
et descendre est faux et rit et passe
une voiture et vous entendez la voiture, c'est-à-dire
en plus du naturel je pense ça aussi
C'est quelque chose dont je ne sais pas si c'est mieux en général
je ne pense pas mais c'est différent
rapide existe avec le bas de ces
domaines
[Musique]
chaque jour
si tu es réveillé à trois heures du matin
demain tu as regardé la vidéo et ça n'arrêtait pas d'augmenter
parce que de l'autre côté du globe
quelqu'un regarderait
[Musique]
et avant de le voir organiquement
75 millions d'amis et de membres de votre famille vous disent
michael bublé a posté votre vidéo et
nous avons dit que ce ne peut pas être ce sera un autre
michael bublé ne vit pas en tanzanie
et on ne se regarde pas appeler avec l'éthique bleue
mettre de nouveaux fronts à partir de 2006, je ne sais pas
ce que nous avons dit tout à coup
baisser ma vision
et excuse moi
[Musique]
ou plus
en tant que musicien tu penses que ça ne t'arrivera pas
jamais ce qui arrive à très peu de gens et
soudain tu vois ce qui t'arrive ou ce qui
peut vous arriver est comme
Je ne sais pas si je suis prêt pour autant
émotions si nous le faisons bien
on peut en vivre quelques années
beaucoup je ne sais pas mais mais maintenant c'est le
Moment sûr on n'avait pas tellement travaillé
dans notre vie et je crois que les trois
Nous sommes entrés dans un monde de
dis OK
à présent
[Musique]